the CW and DC team up for an hour of
power discover the origins it's the
first superhero mashup on TV of the
legends of tomorrow and see the dawn of
the Justice League featuring a special
peek at the Suicide Squad it all starts
this tuesday at nine eight central on
the CW
hey youtubers it's Charlie so what the
hell did you guys just watch there well
it's the beginning of what they're
calling DC week tuesday is like the
beginning of all this DC stuff happening
that's going all week long so here's the
important stuff you guys know that the
flash is coming back on the 19th right
after that on the CW they're airing to
half hour specials one for legends of
tomorrow just to kind of tie up the
series the other for Batman V Superman
Suicide Squad in the DC movie universe
what I'm expecting is that they'll drop
new trailers for Batman V Superman and
suicide squad or at least new footage
during those specials so all you have to
do tuesday after the flash gets done
airing is just keep watching CW just
don't change the channel but there are
two other big Marvel things that are
also happening on tuesday night at the
exact same time so ready you see those
kind of a problem so while the flash is
going to be airing on tuesday night ABC
is going to be airing a captain america
75th anniversary special I'm not
expecting new footage from Captain
America Civil War if they drop it I'll
totally do a new trailer video but
that's why I would DVR that because
there's not going to be a whole lot of
new footage from Civil War but after
that on ABC is the agent Carter premier
agent Carter season 2 episode 1 so I
would recommend that you DVR that if you
want to be safe though I just recommend
DVR and everything if you can do that
here's my recommended watch order for
all this stuff they're just there's way
too much stuff to watch it all at the
same time on tuesday watch the flash
first then watch that Suicide Squad
special then go back and watch the
captain america special then watch asian
Carter this is mostly a DC video so I'll
talk about agent Carter Marvel stuff in
the next marble video that I post this
week but the really big news that they
just announced is that they're bringing
Mira into the Justice League film not
Batman V Superman but Justice League
that movie has not been filmed yet
they're looking to cast Amber Heard for
Mira now if you've never read the comics
you know you're like who the hell is
Mira Mira is the wife of Aquaman in the
comics queen of Atlantis so obviously
she'd be part of Jason Momoa zarkan
Justice League now Jason Momoa is also
showing up in Batman V Superman but
really just just like cameo level he
will barely be in that movie tip of the
spear is exciting that we might be
getting nearer I'm not like a huge Amber
Heard fan but that really doesn't mean
anything I just going to wait till I see
some footage it's going to be a long
time before we see any footage from
justice league next big news item you
may have heard they're doing bizarro on
Supergirl
for spoilers from Supergirl i'm going to
show a couple of pictures from the
recent episode they teased bizarro at
there they just confirmed it the person
that we saw at the end of episode 9 is
bizarro this is going to be super girls
version of bizarro thumb attica lee
she's going to be really close to the
comic book idea of bizarro but she's
being created by Maxwell Lord who is
kind of like this pseudo Lex Luthor type
character in the Supergirl universe you
guys are also probably still wondering
the same thing that I'm wondering is
Maxwell Lord on Supergirl going to be a
telepath or have they changed the
character a little I think that he's
still going to be a telepath they're
probably just holding off on that
Supergirl just had its big TCA panel in
the new president there's like a new
president of CBS television who said you
know maybe maybe we can do a flash
crossover we'll just wait and see what
happens so slightly more optimistic than
what the previous president said the
minute it was announced last year the
greg berlanti s group the people that do
flash and arrow were also going to be
doing Supergirl people were like are
they going to crossover are we going to
see like some kind of Justice League
thing going on because CBS bought the
show and they're a different network
from CW the CBS president at the time
was like you know we're just going to
keep her to ourselves for now it turned
into a big hit but then she ended up
moving on to other things quote unquote
based basically like leaving her job she
was replaced new president is like well
we'll wait and see so Andrew Kreisberg
who is the showrunner on flash and an
executive producer on Supergirl said
that if they can figure it out in the
next month that we might even see a
Supergirl cross over as soon as the end
of this season so best case scenario
before the end of the season on the
flash you will see a Supergirl crossover
worst case scenario you'll see it in
season 2 sometime I just I think people
are really excited about the idea so the
network people like the business people
that actually control this or like okay
you know maybe maybe we'll do this if
people really want it and if you really
like it when they do crazy comic book
stuff like king shark on the flash the
producers have said they really want to
do you know really crazy comic book
stuff and just they have to work up to
it so at some point if we're going to
see bizarro like the craziest comic book
thing that I could possibly think of
would be like the flash legends of
tomorrow team you know like the TV
version of the Justice League that we
already have with those characters
versus their bizarro characters from
another universe now you remember I said
that bizarro on Supergirl is going to be
created by Maxwell Lord she's more of a
Frankenstein type character it's
not alternate universe it's not like a
multiverse explainer for bizarro world
in the comics there is a bizarro world
that shaped like a cube that they go to
every once in a while but it sounds like
Supergirl is taking the more practical
approach you know Frankenstein creates a
monster that is bizarro my long-running
idea for Supergirl flash crossovers just
to overcome any story narrative
difficulties is just to say Supergirl is
happening on a different earth in a
different universe so if you have super
girl jumping Earth's you can have
bizarro Justice League jumping Earth's
so that that would be like the most
comic book thing I could think of so let
me know in the comments if they're going
to be crossing over all these TV
universes what is the craziest comic
book storyline you can think of that
they can do with characters as they've
already created I could see all the big
Geoff Johns fans in the background
raising their hands going blackest night
do blackest night we want green lantern
that would be awesome that would be like
DC's version of doing a TV zombie story
but the problem is is that you have to
use so many big characters they would
apply be way too expensive maybe someday
in like five or six years they'll figure
it out when it's cheap enough to do all
those special effects let me know if you
guys want me to do a bizarro video like
a special bizarre video for Supergirl
because there are a lot of really cool
bizarre of stories in the comics most of
the classics Silver Age bizarro stories
are just really silly so I'm totally
happy to do a video for the history of
bizarro but I also apply be doing on
Marvel agent Carter Captain America
video pretty soon two white guys wait
for all that stuff in case you haven't
seen it the Star Wars people we're
talking about episodes 8 and 9 they
teased a couple big things you can click
here for that video and you can click
here for all my Suicide Squad Batman
beat Superman videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you